[Musique]
salut maroni qu'est ce que tu vas nous
faire découvrir aujourd'hui au démon caf
on va pas à l'ena dispositif super
pratique pour les personnes porteuses de
handicap
le pass transport le pass transport
comment ça marche ça adonne un peu je
vais te donner tous les détails c'est
beau c'est le parent transforme
d'intérêts privés mois
[Musique]
je vous retrouve à s'adonner à leur
encontre demandé chantal malvoyantes
elle utilise le pass transport depuis
2008 grâce à ce dispositif
elle peut se déplacer en toute sérénité
ce moyen de paiement du permet d'être
complètement autonome
marie-chantal bonjour bonjour
racontez nous un peu comment utiliser
pas se transforme la nuit en taxi et
appelle tard chine cherche en vain
devant la maison la permanence aux
médias les dépose au mac
pourquoi ce dispositif il ya au vauban
taxi d'un plus l'ouvrir fais mes courses
pourquoi l'important pour le taximètre
rapport d'amano épouse parce que les
mieux les moins dangereux les moins
dangereux que je me prends le wiels ou
les saunas pied taxe immédiatement avec
les courses vous l'achetez bonne sachet
de compet ou de plus facile de prendre
un taxi comprend le parc oui il est plus
facile parce que d'embûches plus
compliqué de taxiphone à l'union sont
pas trop forts comme un lourd effet pour
une course difficile
mais imagine merci les manifs ont peur
de rien
[Musique]
grâce au pass transport des personnes en
situation d'handicap peuvent se déplacer
en taxi le frais de transport sont
prises en charge avec ce moyen de
paiement ils peuvent se rendre chez le
médecin ou faire leurs courses au total
ce sont 13 imier bénéfices et à qui tu
les deux passes transforce toute l'ue
ja c'est une bonjour bonjour comment
fonctionne le par transport c'est un
dispositif daip qui permet aux personnes
en situation d'handicap de se déplacer
plus facilement favorise leur autonomie
et qui peut en bénéficier
les pass transport sont destinés aux
adultes handicapés justifiant d'une
reconnaissance la commission des droits
et de l'autonomie et ne nécessitant pas
de véhicule adapté ou d'accord et
comment ils peuvent utiliser le pass
transport ils peuvent l'utiliser auprès
des taxiteurs conventionné par le
département en 2021 environ 260 taxis
ont été conventionnée par la
collectivité justement quel est le
montant attribué c'est une aide
individuelle annuelle de 300 euros
versée sous forme de chèque nominatif de
3 euros donc chaque bénéficiaire perçoit
deux chéquiers de ses comptes chèques à
l'année et depuis 2013 l'aide est
attribué pour trois ans n'diaye question
quelles sont les démarches à suivre pour
en bénéficier il faut s'inscrire auprès
de la direction de l'autonomie les
inscriptions se font entre le 1er
juillet et le 30 septembre par la suite
un formulaire et transmis aux
bénéficiaires et les chéquiers sont
distribués en début d'année par courrier
recommandé mais c'est beaucoup y avait
rien à gagner
théâtre au dispositif ce sont donc des
hommes et des femmes qui passent tous
les trois déplacements des personnes en
situation d'handicap les agents du
département travaillent au quotidien
pour favoriser leur autonomie
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur le pass transport
n'hésitez pas vous avez toutes les
coordonnées qui s'affiche sur votre
écran le département des générations
c'est fini si vous souhaitez revoir cet
épisode ainsi que le précédent rendez
vous sur nos sites et réseaux sociaux
quant à moi je vous retrouve très vite
pour rénover les pinèdes à bientôt
la semaine prochaine nous irons dans un
barber shop ici au port son propriétaire
a pu lancer son activité grass otage le
tremplin pour l'activité des jeunes une
aide financière qui favorise l'insertion
dans la vie professionnelle
[Musique]